[Musique]
ce soir avec Anthony Saint-Léger bonsoir
Anthony bonsoir Antoine bonsoir à tous
Anthony depuis une dizaine de jours de
nombreux contes sur les réseaux sociaux
font du 24 septembre une date importante
quelque chose d'exceptionnel devrait
avoir lieu il s'appuie notamment sur le
discours d'un député allemand Antony
effectivement Frédéric Mertz de la CDO
et dans la vidéo que l'on va découvrir
et bien il fait une allocution au bout
de stack l'Assemblée parlementaire
allemand jetez un coup d'oeil surtout au
sous-titre si vous ne parlez pas
allemand évidemment écoutez
je sais exactement où j'étais une date à
retenir donc selon Frédéric Mertz les
mots de ce 24 septembre 2022 date a
priori donc mémorable déclaration
intrigante Anthony preuve en croire
selon certains d'une catastrophe
annoncée effectivement apocalypse une
grande panne générale d'électricité un
blackout général c'est une thématique
d'ailleurs qui revient pas mal sur Tik
Tok et notamment aux États-Unis on peut
la retrouver assez assez souvent sur les
réseaux sociaux
la séquence virale que l'on a vu on peut
l'avoir vu notamment sur Facebook on
voit ce commentaire qui bien qui parle
bien de blackout annoncé il y a aussi
Twitter évidemment où cette internaute
par exemple s'inquiète de cette date que
diable prépare-t-il lui qui a publié la
vidéo en question et puis également sur
Tik Tok par exemple cette vidéo que l'on
découvre ici a été vu millions deux fois
et cette internaute d'évoquer donc cette
date du 24 septembre ce blackout est de
parler pêle-mêle du 11 septembre 2020
2001 des attentats meurtriers les
États-Unis et du décès aussi de la reine
Elisabeth II cette panne serait suivie
d'un grand redémarrage d'une grande
réinitialisation bref d'un great reset
great reset s'alimente les fantasmes des
des complotistes les plus chevronnés
l'idée d'un grand complot donc pour
contrôler le monde l'idée de d'imposer
un nouvel ordre mondial sauf que great
risette c'est quoi et bien c'est le nom
d'un livre en l'occurrence celui de
klaush Fab fondateur du Forum économique
mondial qui a publié donc ce livre en
juin 2020 pour appréhender l'après covid
19 sur le plan économique et d'ailleurs
c'en est devenu un programme du Forum
économique mondial un programme de
reconstruction
économique post pandémie pourtant dans
l'extrait que vous nous avez montré
Anthony il est bien question du 24
septembre mais c'est un lapsus
expliquez-nous effectivement il n'en
faut pas plus un pour donner du grain à
moudre au complotiste ces mots ont bel
et bien été prononcés par Friedrich
merde ce que l'on voit ici mais c'est
une erreur et la confirmation elle nous
a été donnée aux observateurs de France
24 par le porte-parole de la Cedeo du
groupe parlementaire en tout cas de la
Cedeo Friedrich merde n'avait pas en
tête le 24 septembre mais le 24 février
24 février souvenez-vous la Russie
envahit l'Ukraine le début de la guerre
donc et c'est pourquoi le 24 février
parce que ce discours a lieu le 27
février trois jours après et en effet
lorsque l'on recherche sur Youtube avec
les mots suivants merde Bundes stack et
date du 24 septembre en allemand et bien
vous retrouvez ici la vidéo originelle
une originale une vidéo d'une vingtaine
de minutes en date donc du 27 février et
dans son discours devant ses collègues
et bien Frédéric Mertz apporte son
soutien aux Ukrainiens et dénonce la
responsabilité de Vladimir Poutine la
phrase virale a donc été abrégée vous
l'aurez bien compris pour donner lieu à
toutes les interprétations possibles une
erreur reconnue donc par Frédéric Mertz
erreur corrigée aussi sur la version le
site officiel du Bundes stack lors de
ces retranscriptions des différentes
sessions plénières et dans la le
compte-rendu écrit justement vous voyez
qu'il est bien fait mention du 24
février 2022 et en aucun cas du 24
septembre 2022 un lapsus donc et bien il
n'en faut pas plus pour diffuser assez
rapidement une infox à vitesse grand V
rassurez-vous donc 24 septembre 2022
rien de prévu à priori un lapsus on
l'aura donc compris il n'en fallait pas
plus pour les complotistes merci
beaucoup pour toutes ces explications
Anthony Saint-Léger votre chronique info
intox elle est naturellement à retrouver
sur notre site internet france 24.com
voilà c'est la fin de sparey direct
restez avec nous on revient d'ici
quelques minutes sur France 24